[Music]
the box said
leave it in for 10 to 15 minutes i was
in my early 20s
slathering relaxer on my hair in the
bathroom of my small dc apartment
willing it to be as straight as possible
and thinking why not leave it in for 20.
my beauty philosophy was like my cooking
philosophy a little less here
a little extra there except as it turns
out altering the texture of your hair
with a chemical relaxer is
not cooking it's signs and in science if
you don't follow a procedure to a t
it turns out things can and will go
wrong
it was just a few days later that i was
standing in front of that same bathroom
mirror looking at a head of
rough limp over processed hair
each time i ran my comb through it
several strands would break
and fall to the cold tile floor now i
know what you're thinking
i know where the story goes she cuts it
all off starts anew
and now she's rocking that dope set of
curls i had to cut it right
i didn't for weeks i continued to wash
and straighten that head of damaged hair
each morning as i got ready for work i
would watch as more and more strands
fell to the ground as i combed and i did
nothing
i did nothing because i didn't know what
else there was to do
even in the face of irreversible damage
i could not picture a me
without straight hair i was already
curvier than most
my complexion dark the last foothold i
had in the realm of what i consider to
be beautiful was that head of hair and
without it
who was i going to be
here i was in my early 20s having
something of an identity crisis
for most of my life i had adhered to
certain standards of beauty that had
been ingrained into me by the media
my experiences and those around me that
if my hair was
longer straighter my skin lighter my
body a different shape
that i would be more worthy more loved
that i would be beautiful
even if you've never clung desperately
to straight hair the way i did
there are certain beauty standards that
many of us will never meet
yet feel compelled to aspire to what i
want you to remember is this
better beauty is diverse and inclusive
beauty
today i'm going to explain how beauty is
failing all of us
from our beauty standards to our retail
ecosystem
using my own tumultuous hair journey
so eventually my hair hit the point
where i had to do something
it's how i ended up in the salon just a
few weeks later listening to my stylist
suggest that i go forth with a big chop
and wear my natural hair twas or teeny
weeny afros were in
but in afro i couldn't do it
that couldn't have been any farther from
what i'd learned to be beautiful as a
child
you see in our society eurocentric
features are the gold standard in beauty
we value thinner longer hair lighter
skin
and a certain body type over all others
while beauty standards cause all of us
harm they disproportionately work
against black and brown women
my hair as it grows out of my head those
kinky coily curls my stylist love so
much or my richly hued skin
have not only been implicitly rejected
but explicitly devalued
during slavery the cutting of the hair
of slaves was routine
and slave masters continually expressed
disgust at the sight of black hair
in the 19th century black hair was often
not even called hair
rather it was labeled and ridiculed as
wool
this was the beginning of a binary
system of good hair
and bad hair good hair
was manageable and neat it was white
hair
bad hair was nappy and uncontrollable
it was black hair
that ideal has permeated our society
and influences what we consider to be
appropriate and acceptable across
every sphere of our lives that's no
better proven
than in a duke university study
published just last year
where two groups evaluated the same
black female candidate
the first group saw that candidate with
straight hair and the second group
with curly hair that first group rated
that candidate
as more professional and more strongly
recommended for an interview
can you imagine losing out on a
promotion because you chose to embrace
your authentic self
it's not just a loss for black women
like me it's a loss for
the organizations that we're a part of
our beauty standards
they're unhealthy restrictive even
racist
they don't serve you or me for that
matter
remember this better beauty is diverse
and inclusive beauty
so eventually i made the decision to
slowly let my natural hair grow out and
cut off the relaxed hair
the hardest part of my journey i thought
was over
except i had just encountered the real
struggle
shopping for beauty products i would
walk into the local sephora eager to
find something that would cater to my
newly emerging curls
as i moved past walls of homogeneous
advertisements dotted with one or two
models of color
i would feel that hot stink of
non-belonging creep up into my chest
that was only reinforced as i shopped
i'd scan products aisle by aisle trying
not to succumb to the frustration that
comes with limited options
all while being hyper aware of the
associates who would follow me around
close enough to make sure i didn't steal
but far enough to make sure they didn't
have to answer my questions
you can look at retail and see that
beauty is failing us
in a study commission by sephora just
last year
over 74 percent of shoppers feel that
beauty marketing fails to show a diverse
range of skin tones
hair textures and body types and over
half of black shoppers have experienced
bias or unfair treatment on the basis of
race or skin color
this is a fact that is contradictory to
the impact that black and brown women
have on the beauty market as a whole
black people for instance make up just
15 of the population
yet we make up nearly 22 of the us
beauty market
and black and brown women on average buy
beauty products more frequently
and in greater quantities than any other
demographic
you'd expect with such an outsized
contribution
that beauty retailers would be clamoring
to carry the brands that serve us
many of which are created by black and
brown founders and yet today
only three percent three percent
of sephora's brands are black owned
so why does beauty retail matter so much
the beauty industry gains its power
by telling our society what we deem to
be attractive and valuable
and what is not psychological
manipulation is the foundation upon
which beauty is built
what you see when you go into target to
replace that shampoo
or run into sephora to get a new
foundation it matters
and if you're like me and you struggle
to find the products that meet your
needs
or aren't represented in the ads you see
you begin to believe that you're not
just
invisible but that you're physically
undesirable
in my little studio apartment i had felt
lost as to who i was
but let me tell you about the day i met
myself
i was 25 back in that same seat in my
silas salon
shrouded behind a thick mask of
self-doubt she had been impossible to
find
but that day as my stylist placed that
last curl and a head of now fully
natural hair
i caught a glimpse of a woman i hadn't
known before
she was bold she was proud
but most importantly she attacked an
endless well of self-love and
self-confidence that came from
pushing aside a broken beauty system and
finally
finally feeling comfortable in her own
skin
now let me be clear this isn't a story
about finding freedom by moving from
relaxed to natural hair
this is a story about making room for
all of who we are
by stepping outside of a box that none
of us should have to live by
and that that is the story we all
deserve to have
it's the reason why i'm building
beautocracy
a platform that elevates diverse and
inclusive beauty and makes it easier for
women of color to shop and discover skin
care
in an environment that reflects their
worth
our community is built on the idea that
better beauty is about giving back the
power of choice
in the retail environment of creating
space for those around us to achieve
more without being held back by bias and
expanding the narrative so that we can
all
live our own complex stories
what i want you to remember is this
better beauty is diverse and inclusive
beauty
there are a treasure trove of beauty
brands online created by black and brown
founders with products that work for all
of us
go online search black on beauty brands
discover something new
and incorporate it into your routine
diversify
the brands and the influencers that you
follow on social media
and demand that retailers like sephora
and ulta who have committed to
diversifying their shelves and making
the retail environment more inclusive
actually follow through
my difficult hair journey to self-love
and acceptance
it isn't unique but if we work together
it could be as consumers
we have the power to step outside of the
box that we've been given
and change beauty for the better